[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ما فيدا
باسيل وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
واحداث وتتفاعل اخرى نبدا من تونس حيث
تاتين هذه اللقطات وتتواصل عمليات فرز
الاصوات للانتخابات التشريعيه التي اجريت
اليوم صار كثير من الجدل
في تونس بعد مقاطعه معظم الاحزاب الرئيسيه
بالبلاد فرز الاصوات متواصل في اول
انتخابات تشريعيه منذ اجراءات الرئيس
التونسي هيئه الانتخابات تصف المشاركه
بالمتواضعه وتقول ان نسبتها بلغت
88% سعيد يصفها بالتاريخيه حركه النهضه
ترحب بالموقف الشعبي من الانتخابات وجبهه
الخلاص تقول ان المشاركه انها ما وصفته
بالمسرحيه وتقول ان مسؤوليه المعارضه باتت
اكثر وضوحا
من جديد بخموت جبهه مشتعله في الشرق
الاوريني القوات الاوكرانيه تدفع بتعزيزات
كبيره وتقول ان بلدات في محيط المدينه
تتعرض لقصف الروسي الكثيف وزعمول
الانفصاديين المواليين لموسكو يتحدث عن
قرب احكام الحصار على المدينه
الاستراتيجيه بالتعاون مع مجموعه فاجنر
وبعد اجتماعه لقاده مراكز العمليات
المشاركه في اوكرانيا بوتن يطالبون
بمقترحات لاجراءات فوريه ومتوسطه مدى بشان
سير العمليه
انا وقع استمرار العمليه العسكريه التركيه
في الشمال السوري انقر تقول انه لا العراق
ولا سوريا ستكون امنتين لمن سمتهم
بالارهابيين ومسك تقول انها تتفهم مخاوف
انقره وان العمليه البريه سابقه لاوانها
وقد تؤدي الى مزيد من التصعيد
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد اعلى من
الحصاتنا الرقميه ناقصنا مشاركات العرب في
مونديال قطر
2022 حيث لاعين الاداء التاريخي للمنتخب
المغربي الذي وصل المربع الذهبي كما كان
اداء منتخبي السعوديه وتونس لافتا وان لم
يتجاوزها عتبه المجموعات والاستطلاع
ارائكم بهذا الشان كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي
هل تعتقدون ان اداء المنتخبات العربيه
يبنى عليه في البطولات المقبله 66 في
المئه قالوا نعم ان اداء المنتخبات
العربيه يشكل تطورا مدروسا يبنى عليه
بينما اجاب اربعه وثلاثون في المئه بلا
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
ايلا الناس خطوه للوراء لا تطفئ جدوى
الجدل بشان مستقبل تويتر
وبعد الحصاد مباشره وتحديدا في الساعه
12:00 و 5 دقائق بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
تتابعون الجوله الرياضيه اليوميه يوميات
المذيعه التي ترصد المستجدات مستجدات كاس
العالم قطر 2022
[موسيقى]
يتواصلوا فرز واصوات اول انتخابات تشريعيه
تونسيه منذ اجراءات الرئيس قيس سعيد
الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات قالت
ان نسبه الاقبال على التصويت كانت متواضعه
مقارنه بما كانت عليه بالانتخابات السابقه
وصوت التونسيون لاختيار نواب البرلمان
القادم واسطه مقاطعه القوى السياسيه
المعارضه بينما وصفها الرئيس سعيد بن فرصه
التاريخيه للقطع مع الماضي وقال مركز شاهد
لمراقبه الانتخابات انه رصد عمليات توزيع
اموال في محيط احد مراكز الاقتراع وسجل
خرقا للصمت الانتخابيه
هي الانتخابات البرلمانيه الرابعه التي
تشهدها تونس بعد الثوره لكنها لا تشبه
السابقاتها فالتصويت فيها على الافراد لا
على قوائم حزبيه اقبال المصوتين كان بطيئا
خصوصا خلال ساعات الصباح لكن هيئه
الانتخابات رات في النسب المسجله على مدى
اليوم مؤشرات ايجابيه مقارنه بالمواعيد
السابقه
بالتجربه انتخابات نعلم ان جزء كبير من
الناخبين يتوجه في الساعات الاخيره ولكن
حتى بالمقارنه مع المواعيد الانتخابيه
السابقه بما في ذلك استفتاء 25 جوليا
والانتخابات التشريعيه لسنه 2019 في هذا
المعدل في الساعتين هو تقريبا المعدل
العام المعتمد في المعايد الانتخابيه في
تونس ولم يخلو يوم الانتخابي من رسائل
السياسه فالرئيس اعتبر هذه الانتخابات
فرصه تاريخيه للقطع مع من وصفهم بمخربي
البلاد
توكلوا على الله
واعملوا من اجلي
ان نقطه
مع من هؤلاء الذين نحبوا البلاد وخربوا
ونصب انفسهم اوصياء على الشعب التونسي
بطريقه اقتراعا بائده
الانتخابات التي لم يخلو سياقها العام
ايضا من جدل قانوني محتدم بشان الفصول
المعدله من قانونها الانتخابيه
بدون اي مترشح 10 دوائر
التشريعي هذا
المتعلق بالانتخابات 17
ديسمبر كان مسار احادي الجانب بدون
تشاركيه في سياقته لم تتوه صفحه
الانتخابات التشريعيه بعد انتهاء هذا
اليوم المرور الى جوله انتخابيه ثانيه
يبدو امرا حتميا في عدد من الدوائر في
وفقا للقانون الانتخابي يشترط للفوز بمقعد
في مجلس النواب
طول مترشح على الاغلبيه المطلقه من اصوات
ناخبي دائره
الرهان السياسي لهذه الانتخابات يراوح
بينما ذهب اليه الرئيس بالقطيعه مع ما
وصفها بمنظومه غلبت عليها الحسابات
السياسيه على حساب مصلحه البلاد وبين
القوى السياسيه المعارضه له التي ترى ان
هذه الانتخابات لن تنتج سوى برلمان بلا
صلاحياته ومزيد من احكام قبضه الرئيس على
مقاليد السلطه ميساء فاطمه الجزيره تونس
وفي ردود الفعل الاولى على الانتخابات
التشريعيه علقت حركه النهضه في تدوينه لها
على نتائج الانتخابات بالقول شكرا للشعب
التونسيه العظيم ويسقط الانقلابه كما
اعتبرت قياده معارضه في جبهه الخلاص
الوطني نسب المشاركه الاوليه في
الانتخابات دليل على سقوط الشرعيه
ومشروعيه الرئيس ولوحات تلك القيادات
وبالتصعيد الميداني داعيه الى انتخابات
الرئاسيه المبكره في حين وصف القيادي وفي
جبهه الخلاصه الوطنيه جوهر بن مبارك يوم
الانتخابات في اليوم العظيمه وتاريخيه
وبانه المسرحيه وحسم الامر وترك المنقلب
في اضيق الزوايا معتبران ان مسؤوليه
المعارضه صارت اكثر وضوحا وهي وضع التصور
الوطني الكفيل باخراج البلاد من المستنقع
الانقلابه من خلال انتخابات الرئاسيه
المبكره عاجله ونزهه بحسب كلماته
ينضم الينا من تونس مراسل جزيره سيف الدين
بوعلاج سيف الدين مات من المتوقع ان تسطر
النتائج وضعنا في صوره هذا اليوم
الانتخابي كيف مر
اييي نعم
في الحقيقه تقول الهيئه انها من يسمح لها
القانون الانتخابي بان تعلن نتائج بعد
ثلاثه ايام ولكن ااه وفقه ااا نسبه
المشاركه التي اعلن عنها فاروق معسكر رئيس
هيئه الانتخابات ثمانيه فاصل ثمانيه من
الناخبين شاركوا في هذه الانتخابات هذه
النسبه هي الادنى همم اضعف منذ سنه 2011
منذ الثوره التونسيه نحن هذا الاستخاره
الانتخابي هو ثامن استحقاق انتخابه على
امتداد 10 سنوات مثل ما اشرتها اضعف
بالتالي بالنظر الى ان عدد المخترعين كان
ضعيفا س ايه تتم عمليه الفرز بسرعه ومرونه
همم بالمقارنه ايضا مع الانتخابات همم
السابقه هيئه الانتخابات لها تفسيرات
وتاويلات لنسبه المشاركه همم ضعيفه كما
وصفها بو عسكري يقول اولا ان الحمل
تحسيسيه لم ترقى الى المستوى المطلوب
بالنظر طبعا الى طبيعه القانون الانتخابي
الجديد الذي اقره الرئيس قيس سعيد عبر
مرسومه للانتخابات
تتم على اساس على اساس الافراد وليس على
اساس القوائم الحزبيه وبالتالي الاحزاب
السياسيه لم تشارك طبعا المعارضه همم
لمعارضه الرئيس قيس سعيد قاطعوا هذه
الانتخابات ودعوا الناخبين الى مقاطعه
الانتخابات
ومثلتي في بعض المواقف السريعه بعد صدور
هذه النتائج همم
معارضه تعتبر ان نجحت في الدعوه لمقاطعه
الانتخابات ولكن تفسيرات همم السلطات او
الهيئه هيئه الانتخابات تختلف همم طبعا
همم بعد ربما ساعه من الان ستكون هناك
الندوه صحفيه لجبهه الاخلاص الوطني لعرض
موقفها مما حدث طبعا
لن تكون ربما بنفس ذات الاهميه اعلان
نتائج فداء بالنظر الى ان مرشحين ترشحوا
بصفه بفرديه همم الاغلبيه الساحقه من
المترشحين لا ينتمون الى احزاب لم تكن لهم
مشاركه سياسيه همم سابقه وبالتالي نتائج
الانتخابات لن تؤثر على ال- ال- ال-
المساج العام وانما نسبه المشاركه هي التي
ربما قد تؤثر على الشرعيه البرلمان المقبل
مثل ما تعرفين في هذه هي همم هو هذا هو
الدور الاول من الانتخابات وبالتالي هناك
دور ثاني بمجرد اعلان نتائج النهائيه ولكن
الجدل الاساسي والكبير سيكون حول نتائج
الانتخابات
ثمانيه فاصل الثمانيه بالمئه في نعم
كنت معنا من تونس
سيكون لنا نقاش او ساعه بشان هذا
الانتخابات ولكن اذا توقف مع ابرز المحطات
التي شهدتها تونس منذ الخامس والعشرين من
يوليو لعمل المعطيح
في الخامسه والعشرين من يوليو 2021 الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد يصدر سلسله قرارات
الاستثنائيه اعلن بموجبها اقاله الحكومه
برئاسه شابلنشاشي وتجميد عمل البرلمان
برئاسه راشد الغنوشي لمده شهر في الرابع
والعشرين من اغسطس 2021 اعلن سعيد تجميد
عمل البرلمان حتى شعار الاخر واصفا اياه
بالخطر على الدوله في التاسع والعشرين من
سبتمبر 2020 الرئيس سعيد يكلف نجلاء بودا
بالتشكيل الحكومه في الثالثه عشر من
ديسمبر من العام نفسه سعيد يعني باستمرار
تجميلي عمل البرلمان حتى تنظيم الانتخابات
من تشريعيه جديده في السابعه عشر من
ديسمبر 2022
يناير 2022 ارتفاع الدين الخارجي لتونس
الى 41 مليار دولار ما يشكل نحو 83% من
النات المحلي الاجمالي في الخامس من
فبراير الماضي سعيد يعلن حل المجلس الاعلى
للقضاء بعد ان اتهمه اعضاء فيه بالفساد
والولاء لحركه النهضه في الثلاثين من
مارسي الماضي وبعد ساعات قليله على عقد
البرلمان المعلق جلسه عامه افتراضيه
واصداره قانونا يلغي كل اجراءات سعيد
الاستثنائيه الرئيس يقرر حلل مجلس النيابي
معتبرا ان ذلك القرار جاء للحفاظ على
الشعب ومؤسسات الدوله في الثانيه والعشرين
من ابريل سعيد يصدر امرا لاسيا بتعديل
القانون الاساسي وتركيبه الهيئه العليا
المستقله للانتخابات ليصبح مجلس الهيئه
مكونه من سبعه اعضاء يتم تعيينهم بامر
رئاسي في التاسعه عشر من مايو الماضي بس
عيدي يصدر مرسوم الرئاسيه بتشكيل الهيئه
الوطنيه الاستشاريه من اجل جمهوريه جديده
والتي من مهامها ودستور جديد للبلاد في
الحادي والثلاثين من الشهر نفسه قوانت
تونسيه معارضه للرئيس تعلن تكوين جبهه
باسم الخلاص الوطني برئاسه احمد الشابي في
الثلاثين من يونيو الرئيس سعيد ينشر مشروع
الدستور الجديد الذي سيتم الاستفتاء عليه
بعد ذلك بثلاثه ايام رئيس هيئه الوطنيه
الاستشاريه المكلفه بصياغه الدستور الصادق
بالعيد يتبرا من مشروع الدستور ويعتبر انه
يمهد لنظام بالتاتريا شائم في الخامسه
والعشرين من يوليو التصويت على مشروع
الدستور الجديد بمشاركه نحو 27% من من يحق
لهم التصويت واربعه 94%
يصوطون بنعم سبتمبر 2022 الحكومه التونسيه
ترفع اسعار غاز الطهي والوقود والاسواق
تشهد ندره في مواد استهلاكيه اساسيه مثل
السكر والحليب والزيت النباتي
نوفمبر 2022 مدن تونسيه تشهد زياده لافته
في عدد الاحتجاجات المهدده بالاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والاتحاد العام للشغل يحذر من
انفجار اجتماعي ال17 من ديسمبر 2022 بدا
الاقتراعي في اول انتخابات تشريعيه وفق
الدستور الجديد
والمحلل السياسي كما ينضم الينا ايضا من
تونس خالد البارودي الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي سيد بالحسن كيف يمكن تفسيرها هذه
النسبه الضعيفه من الاقبال على هذه
الانتخابات على الرغم من ان الرئيس سوق
لها لانها منعرج تاريخي وفرصه تاريخيه
الحقيقه ليس هناك اي تفسير او اي تبرير
يقدم لهذه النسبه المخلله للمشاركه في
الانتخابات نعم يمكن الحديث عن تظاهر
الكثير من الظروف التي ادت او ساعه
المشاركه لعل اهمها ان الحمله الانتخابيه
كانت فاهه نظرا لمحدوديه الانفاق الذي
اوسخ الانفاق الذي وضعه القانون
الماكينات الحزبيه التي كانت تقوم بدور
كبير في هذه الانتخابات ايضا غياب المال
السياسي الذي كان
ينفقوا خلال الحمل الانتخابيه وحتى يوم
الاختراع كل هذه الاسباب هي تظاهره في
تسجيل هذه المحبه ولكن الفكره الاساسيه هي
ان السماء البارزه في كل المحطات
الانتخابيه في تونس كانت نسبه العزوف على
الانتخابات سجلنا سيما سبق من المناسبات
انتخابيه 60% من نسبه العزوف والان وصلنا
الى حدود اكثر من 90% وهي نسبه كارثيه بكل
المقاييس وهي نسبه حقيقه تعكس هذا المساج
الشعبي هذا المساج الانتخابي الذي يميز
الى الكسل بالمقاطعه يعني هذه الانتخابات
وطبعا عندما
تتحدثين
ثقه يعني نتحدث عن كسل من جانب الناخب ام
عدم ثقه في سير العمليه الانتخابيه
والمسار التي ادى لها باختصار لو سمحت
نعم فقط واصل فكره عن العمليه ليست
استجابه لدعوات الاحزاب المعارضه حتى هذه
الاخيره
وعدم الثقه في صانع القرار السياسي
باجمعهم سواء كانت الاحزاب التي اليوم في
المعارضه او تلك التي هي اليوم في المولات
وحتى ربما في شخص الرئيس نفسه كل هذه
العوامل
بالنسبه الى تونس التي اذهبت العالم
العربي والهمه الربيع العربي وهي رائده
سيد خالد البارودي هذه النسبه الضعيفه
بتقديرك الى ماذا تعود ما مردها
مساء الخير الحقيقه انا لا اتفق مع صديق
بن حسن في الحديث عن انها نسبه مخجله
كانما نتحدث عن شيء عاطفي نخله منه هذه
النسبه تؤكد ان شعب التونسي شعب حر وواعي
ويستطيع ان يميز بين الغسل وسميم هذه
النسبه تؤكد على ان شعب التونسي يرفض
النهج الذي ذهب اليه
الصوت لا يصلني قد نعود اليك في سياق
الحصاد مره جديده الى السيد الحسن اليحيوي
سيد بالحسن عندما تصف النسبه بالمخجله اذا
ابتعدنا عن الكلام اللي عاطفي كما يقول
السيد خالد البارودي كيف ينعكس ذلك على
شرعيه هذا البرلمان هل يمكن لاعضاءه اي
يتمتعوا بالشرعيه وهم لم يحصدوا على اكثر
من ثمانيه فاصل ثمانيه في المئه من نسبه
المخترعين
هو للاسف هذه هي النسبه المتدنيه للمشاركه
في الانتخابات ليس لها اي اثر قانوني ولا
تسحب الشرعيه
القانونيه على المستوى السياسي نعم يمكن
للبعض وخاصه استثمار هذه الارقام المسجله
ومحاولات لتصويرها على انها استجابه
لدعوات الاحزاب البرلمانيه
حقيقيه لكن بامكان هذه الاحزابلان حقيقيه
ان تدفع بها للتسويق بالاوراق البيضاء مثل
ما دعونا ذلك اثناء الصوت
والذ سيد ابن الحسن انت تتحدث عن دور
الاحزاب المعارضه وثقل هذه الاحزاب ولكن
سؤالي كان لك عن كيف عن دور هذا البرلمان
وكيف سيتحرك وكيف سى يشرع وهو لم يحصل سوى
على ثقه
8.8 من التونسيين كيف يمكن له ان يكون
ممثلا للامه وهذا دور الحقيقي
ليس هناك اي اثر قانوني فرق قانون
الانتخابي ليس هناك مثل محدده او عتبه
بناء عليها
الانتخابات ومن تحصل على الاغلبيه
المتفرقه 50 زائد واحد في دوائهم سوف يكون
متواجدين في البرلمان او مش المقبل قالنيا
ليس هناك اي اثر واقول للاسف ليس هناك اي
اثر قانوني لهذه النسبه المتدليه الان هذه
النقطه سياسيه جديده لم يحتفي بها الاعلام
ربما كما يجب لكي يتعرف عليهم الناس اكثر
لن يمتلكوا ما يكفي من الموارد الماديه
للقيام بحمله انتخابيه ولكي يصلوا الى كل
الناس ليس هناك هذا المال السياسي الذي
اعتقنا اليه في المناسبات انتخابيه
السابقه ولكن في نهايه الامر شرعيا
قانونيا سوف يكون لمن تحصل على نسبه
الاصوات التي تسمح له بالتواجد في
البرلمان الشرعيه المطلوبه لكي يكون بعمله
ولكن
اسمع منه تعليق سيد خالد البارودي قبل ما
اسمع تعليقك على مذاكره السيد الحسن
اليحيى وينوه لما جاء او ياتي على شاشه
الجزيره من عواجر رئيس المكتب السياسي
لحراك الخامس والعشرين من يوليو في تونس
يدعو الانتخابات الرئاسيه المبكره بعد
المشاركه الضعيفه بانتخابات اليوم سيد
خالد اذن لا اثر قانون لهذه النسبه
الضعيفه ما يعني بان هذا المجلس مادن كما
مضت الخطوات السابقه للرئيس سعيد رغم كل
المعارضه لها
نعم القضيه ليست قضيه
اثار قانونيه بل هي قضيه شرعيه ومشروعيه
رئيس الجمهوريه الان بات معزولا وهذا
النهج الذي ينتهجه اظهر الناخب التونسي
90% من التونسيون اي الاغلبيه المطلقه
انهم لا يوافقون هذا النهج لا يوافقون في
استرادها بالسلطه ولا يوافقون كل هذا
المسار الذي يقوم به من من الدفع الاحزاب
ومن حل المؤسسات الحزبيه وحتى هذه
الانتخابات السوريه ايضا الشعب التونسي
اثبت انه همم يرسل رساله اخرى الى الجهات
الدوليه سواء القويه في تونس او في الخارج
التي يراهانت على رئيس سعيد وكان لسانه
حالها تقول ان هذا الريان يجب مراجعته وان
هذا الخيار لا يوافق عليه اغلب الشعب
التونسي كذلك ايضا يمكن ان رساله اخرى وهي
هامه جدا الى جهات مالحه الى صندوق النقد
الدولي الذي
يعالج ملف تونس وكانما تحدثه على او لا
يوجد نفاق في تونس لا يوجد اجماع في تونس
على كل الخيارات التي يقوم بها رئيس قيس
سعيد بحكمته بالتالي عليه ان يفكر كثيرا
في منح ربما
اموال وقروض لا يوافق عليها شعب التونسي
باعتبار انه يرفض كل هذا المسار وربما
لاحظنا ان السنه
[موسيقى]
منح تونس او نظر في هذا الملف الى مده لم
يعلنها ربه هذه النتيجه
السؤال ماذا عن المعارضه كيف ستتصرف
المعارضه في المرحله
المقبله هي قاطعه استحقاقات ورفضت
استحقاقات سابقه الا ان ذلك لم يغير شيئا
من الواقع على الارض في هذه المرحله بعد
الانتخابات كيف سيكون او ستكون خريطه طريق
تصرف قوى المعارضه
بالعكس انا ارى ان المعارضه استطاعت او
نجحت في في ابعاد الفكره الخاطئه عن رئيس
قيس سعيد من انه رئيس كل التونسيين وان
الشعب في اغلبه معه
والحرائق الذي قامت به ثلث سنه ونصف اجل
الان اكله واصبح اغلب الشعب التونسي يشاطر
الاحزاب السياسيه هذا الراي ويعتقد ان هذا
هذه الحكومه ورئيسها ليسوا قادرين على
اضافه اي شيء التونسيين والوضع الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي
نعم بطبيعه الحال اييي لابد للاحزاب
السياسيه من الاستثمار هذا النهج الرافض
بهذه الخطوات السياسيه
والتوحيد صفوفها بالتاكيد اكثر على نهج ان
النظام السياسي لعوده المؤسسات الشرعيه
والتصدي لكل هذه الحملات التي تستهدف
الشعب التونسي وتستهدف الديمقراطيه
الوليده والانتقال الديمقراطي هذا الذي
قطع فيه اشواقا ولكن
ربما الظروف الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه هي
التي لم تنتج همم شكل المطلوب او الشكل
الذي يحتاجه التونسيون مما جعل بعض همم
الاطراف تنتهي الفرصه وتنقذ على السلطه
وتعود بناء الى مربع الاستبداد الانفراد
بالسلطه والانفراد الحكم
والمحل الاساسي كنت معنا من تونس والشكر
موصول للسيد حسن اليحيوي الكاتب والمحل
السياسي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الى اوكرانيا حيث هو اعلنت كيف حاله
التاهب الجويه في عموم البلاد محضره من
موجه هجمات الروسيه جديده وقالت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها صدت هجوم
الروسيه على اكثر من 20 بلده في مقاطعه
يدونيسيا وان نحو 25 قريه اخرى في محيط
مدينه بخموت تعرضت لقصف روسيا كثيف
وفي حديث ان مستمر عن بخموت قال زعيم
الانفصاليين في دنياك ان قوته بالتعاون مع
مجموعتي فاجنر تقترب من احكام الحصار على
المدينه وان القوات الاوكرانيه تدفع
بتعزيزات كبيره نحو المدينه التي تشهد
المعارك عند اطرافها او تشتد المعارك عند
اطرافها حسب تعبيره
مدينه باخ مت هي احدى مدن مقاطعه دنيا اسك
التي تحاول القوات الروسيه دخولها منذ
الصيف الماضي دون تحقيق اي اختراق ميدانيا
لنتعرف عليها بشكل اكبر
[موسيقى]
منذ بدا الحرب تحاول القوات الروسيه دون
توقف السيطره على جبه موت دون جدوى تقعد
على ضيفه
شماليه مقاطعه دونيتك في اقليم جمباز
شرقيه اوكرانيا وتبعد نحو 600 كيلو متر عن
العاصمه
[موسيقى]
وتعرضت خلال الاشهر اللاحقه لمحاولات
اقتحام عديده احبطتها القوات الاوكرانيه
رمزيات عاليه بعد الانسحاب منخارف يدفعوا
الجيش الروسي بكل ثقله مستعينا بمرتزقه
فاجنر وجنود الاحتياط الذين تم استدعائهم
اخيرا
وبنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه
ومنها تشم فرق المدفعيه والصواريخ ضربات
على المواقع الروسيه
وبينما يستعرض القتال انقطعت خدمات المياه
والكهرباء عن ضخمه التي هجرها معظم سكانها
وتعهد الروس بجعلها مسلخا للجنود
الاوكراني
في موسكو اعلن عن عقد الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين امس الجمعه اجتماعا بقاده
مراكز العمليات المشاركه في اوكرانيا
للوقوف على سير المعارك الدائره هناك وقال
المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه ديميتر
بيسكوف ان الرئيس بوتن اطلع على عمليه تلك
المراكز وعقد اجتماعا ومحادثات منفصله مع
القاده اعرب خلالها عن استعداده للاستماع
الى مقترحاتهم للاجراءات الفوريه
والمتوسطه المدى بشان سير العمليات
العسكريه في اوكرانيا
انضم الينا من اكياس تيموفي
نوف مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني كما ينضم
الينا من موسكو سورجيست ركان الباحث في
المجلس الروسي للشؤون الدوليه ابدا معك
سيد
يوري ساك لو سمحت لي في ما يتعلق بباخ موت
كيف هو الوضع
نعم
تسيطر على هذه المدينه منذ منتصف الصيف
طبعا هم زوجوا بقوات كبيره ولكنهم تكبدوا
خسائر في الارواح
وحتى هم لا يابهون لحياه الناس حتى في من
جنودهم نعم الوضع سيء للغايه واوكرانيا
حشدت مصادرها عسكريه قويه ولكن ضخمه لا
تعدوا هدفا استراتيجيا لكره طرفين كيف
ستدور الامور خلال الاشهر القادمه
الجهتين اذا كيف تفسرون تكثيف الهجمات
عليها في الايام الاخيره
عشان
تريد
خسارتها لمعركه ومعركه خارطه اخيرا معركه
خيرسون القوات الروسيه بشكل نهائي
[موسيقى]
كيف يمكن فهم اعلان الجيش الاوكراني حاله
التاهب الجوي في عموم البلاد ما المقصود
بهذه الحاله وانتشارها على كامل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه من ماذا تخشى
هجماتنا
تتحدث عن امكانيه محاولات القوات الروسيه
لشني هجوم من ضخم خلال فتره القادمه اذا
سيكون انتحاريا بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه
لانهم لما ينجحوا في الشتاء الماضي وكانت
اوكرانيا انا غير مستعده والان بيتنا
مستعدين اذنهم الشتاء قد يكون صعبا
بالنسبه لمسار الحرب ولكنه سيكون مستعدين
لها
على ذلك تتحدثون عن تاريخ محدد الشهر
القادم
نوعه فاروق
ولكن
كبار القاعده العسكريين والوزراء اكدوا
بان هنالك توقعا لهجوم ويعدونه ويستعدون
لمثل هذه الاحتمال
ولكن لاحقا في فصل الشتاء ربما هنالك
احتماليه لشني هجوم ضخمه على جبهات عده
شكرا لك سيد همم
الاوكراني كنت معنا نكيف اعود الان الى
السيد سيرجيس راكان سيد سونجي
ما المقصود بهذا الاجتماع الذي قام به
الرئيس بوتين مع القيادات العسكريه ولماذا
هذه المقترحات هل يشكل ذلك دليلا على
اعتماد نهج روسي جديد في مقاربه هذه الحرب
قد تغيرت وهي تخضع لعمليه
[موسيقى]
في الوقت الحالي ليس هنالك
وفي ارض المعركه وله تاملنا في الخرائط
فاننا
المعارك هي مدلعه في منطقه حيث
[موسيقى]
ليس هنالك ايه
على ما يبدو ان كلا الطرفين
ويحضران للمواجهه قد
في بدايه العام القادم لذلك كلا طرفين ما
زال ملان او لديهما امال بنسبه للعمل
القادم لتكون اللده لهما او اي منهما اليد
العليا في هذه الحرب وابدا نضيف
ان هناك كثير من اساءه التفسير لما يجري
الجمود
الاعلاميه
وحيث اننا خبراء علينا ان نكون محاضرين
وفي اللغه التي نستخدمه
في هجوم
روسيات فوريه ومتوسطه ما المقصود
بالاجراءات الفوريه والمتوسطه كيف يمكن
تفسير ذلك
اوكي
المقترحات التي يتحدث عنها الرئيس بوتين
او طلبها الرئيس بوتن من القيادات
العسكريه طويله المدى ومتوسطه المدام ما
المقصود بهذه العباره
من بدايه العام القادم ليس هنالك اي
تطورات كبيره
عاليه ولكن في متعلق بالراي العام ينتظرون
اوكراني على ما يبدا ثقه بتحقيق النصر
ولكن نحن نحن نعتقد انه
الانتصار في هذه المعركه طبعا ينبغي وضع
وضع
استراتيجيه يتعلق فقط بالجوانب اللوجستيه
مزيد من القوات ولكن ايضا وضعه استراتيجيه
فعاله وناجعها تمكن
من الانتصار في هذه الحرب وفي الوقت
الحالي الرئيس بوتين يتفاعل ويتواصل مع
القاعده على العسكريين
والتي يمكن ان تفسر باع تحضيرا واستعدانا
استعدادا
لحمله عسكريه ضخمه في
العام القادم تبدا مع حلولي العام الجديد
وطبعا فصل الشتاء ربما سيما كلنا من شاني
مزيد من الهجمه او همم
الاوكرانيا اوكرانيا
انخفاض درجات الحراره حيث وهذا يمكنه
الاسلحه الضخمه من التحرك وكذلك انتظارا
لتعزيزات وهذا سيتطلب شكرا
اوردت وكاله سبوتنا في الروسيه للانباء
نقلا عن مصادر مطلعه ان القوات المسلحه
الروسيه تسلم الدفعه جديده من منظومات
استطلاع المدفعيه الصوتيه المعروفه باسم
فنسلان والتي اكدت انها اظهرت كفاءه عاليه
خلال المعارك في اوكرانيا وبحسب المصدر
فان منظومات تكتشفوا تكتشفوا بشكل فعال
مواقع مدفعيه القوات الاوكرانيه وتحدد
احداثياتها لتدميرها على الفاضي وفي وقت
سابق قال مصدر مطلع لسباطنك ان انظمه
فنسلن اثبتت فعاليتها في استهداف في
مدفعيه الناتو المورده للقوات الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
الى شمال سوريا حيث افادت مصادر ومحليه
للجزيره ان الجيش التركي استهدف بالمدفعيه
الثقيله مواقع ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في قرى عده على امتداد الطريق
الدولي ام 4 شمال الرقه واوضحت مصادر
الجزيره ان القصف طال ايضا مواقع لتلك
القوات في قرى اخرى
شمال الحسكه وقالت مواقع اعلاميه مواليه
لما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
مدفعيا تركيا
عين العرب على الحدود السوريه
هذا هو اعلنت وزاره الدفاع التركيه انها
قضت على اثنين من عناصر حزب العمال
الكردستاني في شمال العراق واكدت انه لا
لعراق ولا سوريا سيكون امنا لمن سمتهم
الارهابيين
في هذه الاثناء وصفات الخارجيه الروسيه
العمليه البريه التركيه المخطط لها في
سوريا بالخطوه السابقه لاوانها وبانها قد
تؤدي الى مزيدا من التصعيد وقالت ان هيئتي
الاركان العامه واجهزه الاستخبارات في
البلدين تجر اتصاله والثقه بشان العمليه
العسكريه التي تعتزم تركيا القيامه بها في
سوريا واشارت الخارجيه الروسيه الى ان
موسكو تتعاملوا بفهم مع القضايا الحساسه
لحمايه الحدود التركيه الجنوبيه لانقره
لكنها تنطلق من الحاجه الى تقيد الصارم
بمبادئ وحده اراضي الدوله السوريه
واستقلالها وسيادتها
بينما توسيطر حاله الترقب بشان العمليه
العسكريه التركيه في الشمال السوري تستمر
المساعد دبلوماسيه الروسيه على امل التوسل
الى ارضيه اتفاق ترضي كلا من تركيا
والنظام السوري وما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه قالت الخارجيه الروسيه ان
العمليه البليه التي تخطط لها انقره سابقه
لاوانها ويمكن ان تؤدي الى مزيد من تصعيد
الموقف وتحفز المشاعر الانفصاليه وتفاقم
المواجهه المسلحه لكن موسكو رغم ذلك تتفهم
بواعث القلق الامني لدى انقره
هذا موقف يطالب الاتراك ضمنيا بمزيد من
التريث وتلك رغبه الروسيه معلنه تستهدف ان
عاش قنوات الاتصال بين انقره والنظام
السوري لايجاد مخرج يضمن تامين الجدار
الجنوبي للحدود التركيه ويحول دون توغل
بري تركيا ذكر ذلك بوضوح قبل اسبوع وزير
الخارجيه روسي سيرجي لوفي فقد قال ان
بلاده مهتمه باستئناف الحوار بين تركيا
وسوريا على اساس اتفاق ارضنا الموقع عام
1998 وان المتطلبات الاساسيه نضجت للمضي
قدما في هذا الحوار في اتفاق اذنه يحق
لتركيا ملاحقه منتصفهم بالارهابيين في
الداخل السوري حتى عمق خمسه كيلومترات
واتخاذ التدابير الامنيه اللازمه اذا تعرض
امنها للخطر يريد الروس في هذه المره
قياده حوار بين تركيا والنظام السوري من
اجل العوده الى هذا الاتفاق او تعديله بما
يبدد المخاوف الامنيه تركيا من وجود
الوحدات الكرديه على حدودها الجنوبيه يريد
الروز ايضا ان تحفز مساعدهم قياده ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه على القبول بوضع
جديد يسمح بانتشار قوات النظام السوري في
مناطقهم لتطمئن انقره وتعدل عن التوغل
البري لكن قائده القوات مظلوم عبده ما زال
يعلق اماله على دور امريكي يحول دون عمليه
بليه تركيه دون ان يضطر للتنازل عن مناطق
الاداره الذاتيه لما تعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه موقف يضع المساعي الروسيه
امام تحدي كبير لكن موسكو تعول على
توافقاتها ومصالحها مع انقره في ملفات
ساخنه عده لعل ابرزها تصدير الغاز لانجاح
تلك المساعي حرست لذلك الخارجيه الروسيه
على تاكيد وجود اتصالات وثيقه بين هيئتي
الاركان العامه واجهزه الاستخبارات في
البلدين ورغم تفهم المخاوف الامنيه لانقره
فان منطلق موسكو كما قالت خارجيتها هو
الحاجه الى التقيد الصارم بمبادئ وحده
الاراضي السوريه واستقلالها
السياسي والخبير الاستراتيجي مراد اصلان
سيد مراد بالنظر الى الموقف الروسي هل
ستعدل انقره عن اي تبغل بريه في الشمال
السوري
هذه الوساطه
العسكريه فيما يتعلق في الشارع الاساسيه
وواحده مع الولايات المتحده همم
تلك القوه عن الحدود التركيه وهذا لم يحدث
وبالتالي هنا عمل عمل
حقيقي او تطبيق تلك الاتفاقتين الامر
الاخر
اول رايت ايه اذا كانت الامور
العسكري هو خيار اخر ولكن علينا ان ننتظر
الظروف الماضيه من اجل اي تصعيد او اي عمل
عسكري ولكن نحن نعطي الاولويه للجهد
الدبلوماسي والجهد السياسي قبل الحديث عن
عمل العسكري سيد مراد ما هي الظروف
المناسبه او التي وصفتها بالمناسبه لاي
تواخذ هل موافقه الجانب الروسي تشكل عاملا
حاسما في اي ترهلات
اعتقد ان علينا ان نقرا
وروسيا والولايات المتحده وحتى حزب العمال
الكردستاني طبعا روسيا تريد ان يكون هناك
موجود للقوات السوريه على الحدود الجنوبيه
لتركيا ولكن الولايات المتحده احدثت
انقسام
وموقف تركيا
من قبل السوريين وذلك للمشاركه في عمليه
السياسيه ولكن الهدف الاسماء والاعلى هو
امن تركيا
طبعا كل الجهات لها اجنداتها الخاصه في ما
يتعلق به الملفات
تحدثتم بان الاولويه هي للعمل الدبلوماسي
تجري محادثات وجولات منذ فتره ما الذي
يؤخر الوصول الى صيغه تؤدي الى تراجع
تركيا عن فكره التوغل في الشمال السوري
يريد ان يوقف العمليه العامه ولا يريد ان
يتعهد سياسيا
طبعا قوات حمايه الشعب التركيه تريد ان
تتواجد بحمايه من الولايات المتحده وتركيه
لا تريد ان ترى
فريد شوقي ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
تحت قياده حزب العمال الكردستاني لذلك
تركيا تريد ان تكون هذه المنطقه خاليه من
التواجد لهذه القوات على الاراضي السوريه
المحلل السياسي والخبير الاستراتيجيه مراد
اصلان كنت معنا من انقره شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
قال مالك منصه تويتر
حسابات الصحفيين المعلقه على تويتر وكانت
تويتر علق حسابه 6 صحفيين يعملون في وسائل
اعلام امريكيه وقالت صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان
معظم هذه الحسابات
تناول خبر تجميد حسابي مستخدما بسبب تتبعه
مسار الطائره الخاصه بمالك المنصه ايضا
ماسك
مجددا يدخل الى الماسك مالك منصه تويتر
الجدل السياسيه والاعلاميه الامريكي بقوه
هذه المره مع الاعلاميين الامريكي
السنين الاخيره دون مشاكل تذكر ولم يقف
الامر عند ردود فعل الاعلاميين الامريكيين
منذ الخميس بل وصل الى اروقه الامم
المتحده اذ لم يخفي المتحدث الرسمي باسم
الامين العام خلق الامانه العامه من خطوه
الى الماسك التي اعتبرها سابقه خطيره منصه
تدعي على حد قوله التمسك بحريه التعبير
على تويتر لا ينبغي اسكاتو اصوات وسائل
الاعلام على منصه تدعي انها مساحه لحريه
التعبير من وجهه نظرنا تشكل هذه الخطوه
سابقه خطيره في وقت يواجه فيه الصحفيون في
جميع انحاء العالم الرقابه والتهديدات
الجسديه وحتى اسوا من ذلك وما زلنا على
اتصال مع مسؤوليه تويتر في نيويورك ايضا
طلبت لجنه حمايه الصحفيين الى الماسك
باعاده النظر في قراره التعسفي حسب قولها
واعتبرت اللجنه انه اذا كان الامر يتعلق
بالانتقام من طرف الى الماسك فان ذلك
انتهاك خطير لحريه الصحافه في نقل الاخبار
دون خوف من الانتقام
قرروا الى الماسك كبرره بالحفاظ على امينه
الشخصي والى ان تتضح اسباب اخرى لسدافي
صحفينا امريكيين بعينهم فان الملك الجديد
لتويتر نجح في وقت وجيز مجددا في تاكيد
حضور ودور من السطح تويتر في مختلف
المحافل الامريكيه لاسيما الاعلاميه نصر
حسين الجزيره
[موسيقى]
رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه المكلف على
الفلسطينيين السلام دون سياده وقال الناطق
باسم الرئاسه نبيل ابو ردينه انه لامن ولا
سلام دون عطاء الشعب الفلسطيني حقوقه
واحذر من خطوره سياسه الاسرائيليه التي
وصفها بانها تريد تكريس الاحتلال محمدا
اداره الامريكيه مسؤوليه الوفاء بوعودها
والحفاظ على حل الدولتين والوضع التاريخي
في القدس ومقدساتها وكان نتنياهو قد قال
في مقابله مع الاذاعه العامه الوطنيه
الامريكيه ان السلامه لا يسعى اليه مع
الفلسطينيين
سيكون على اساس من هي مصلحيات حكم ذاتي
دون سياده ومع وجود الامن بيد اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
هذا الحديث يدعونا للتذكير بصيغه الحكم
التي ارسلتها اتفاقيه او ارستها اتفاقيه
اوسلو في تسعينيات القرن الماضي والتي
انشات او انشئت بموجبها السلطه الفلسطينيه
فقد قسمت لاتفاقيه اراضي الضفه الغربيه
الى ثلاث مناطق مع احتفاظ اسرائيل
بسيطرتها على الحدود والامن الخارجي
والقدس والمستوطنات ايضا تشكل المنطقه الف
التي تضم مراكز المدن واحدا وعشرين في
المئه من مساحه الضفه الغربيه وتخضع امنيا
وايضا اداريا للسلطه الفلسطينيه ماذا عن
المنطقه باء تخضع اداريا للسلطه
الفلسطينيه ولكن امنيا تخضع لاسرائيل
وتقدر مساحتها بنحو 18 بالمئه من اراضي
الضفه وهي غالبا مناطق ماهوله في الكره
والضواحي
منطقه جيم فخضع امنيا واداريا بالكامل
للسيطره الاسرائيليه وهي اقل سكانا واكبر
مساحه اذا تشكل وحدها نحو 61% من اجمالي
مساحه الضفه الغربي
بتنص
لها اتفاقيات اوسلو حاله اسرائيل دون
تنفيذي ما جاءت به التسويه انتهت الفتره
الانتقاليه المفترض ان لا تتجاوز خمسه
اعوام دون بلوغ التسويه النهائيه التي
تفضي الى قيام الدوله الفلسطينيه
تركت همم اصله للفلسطينيين سلطه حكم ذاتيه
مؤقته ملزمه ملزمه بالتنسيق الامني وغير
قادره على منع المد الاستيطاني
فبعد اندلاع انتفاضه الاقصى عام 2000
اعاده اسرائيل احتلال جميع المناطق
الخاضعه للسيطره الفلسطينيه في الضفه خلال
الاقل من عامين في عام
2005 انصحبت سلطاته الاحتلال بشكل احادي
من مستوطناتها في قطاع غزه لكنها ما زال
تتوسع في بناء المستوطنات في المناطق التي
احتلتها عام 67 بما في ذلك اجزاء من القدس
الشرقيه
ينضموا الينا من الناصره الدكتور محمود
يسبك استاذ الدراسات الشرق اوساطيه في
جامعه حيفا عبر الهاتف دكتور محمود هذا
العرض الذي طرحه نتنياهو عن حكم ذاتيه
ولكن الامن يعود لاسرائيل وهي سياده
منقوصه اي دلاله يعطي على الناس الذي
ستعتمده هما المقبله تجاه فلسطينيين
وطبعا يعني هنا في هذا التصليح الذي
سمعناه من نتنياه في البارحه وفي الايام
الاخيره يعبر تعبيرا حقيقيا عن النوايا
الاسرائيليه المبيته عمليا منذ يعني توقيع
اتفاقيه اصله حتى يومنا هذا منذ تم توقيع
اتفاقيه اوسلو حتى يومنا هذا الوضع
الفلسطيني هو انه في منطقه سي على الاقل
هنالك منطقه استيطان مستمره متواصله وهدف
هذا الاستطاعه طريقه وضع الاستيطان
لعدم التواصل لوضع منطقه لا تتواصل
جغرافيا الفلسطينيه
وهذا الهدف تم الاعلان عنه يعني في بدايه
الثمانينات في اسرائيل وليس حديثه اليوم
يؤكد على هذا وعمليه ان يكون الفلسطينيين
انه لا يعني امل لكم في ظل الحكومه
الحاليه وفي ظل الاوضاع الدوليه ان تكون
دوله فلسطين او حتى نفتح بمفا الجديده مع
الفلسطينيين فهذا هو الوضع الحقيقي الذي
تعيشه المنطقه وخاصه مواضع الفلسطيني بانه
اسرائيل تنوي وهذه الحكومه الحاليه
الجديده هي حكومه من اجل توسيع الاستيطان
والقدم
الصف الغربيه همم وسيطر اسرائيل عليها نعم
الدولي مع هذه الطرحات الاكثر التطرفا حسب
ما يبدو
انا اعتقد ان المجتمع الدولي لن يتحرك
طالما انه الانظمه العربيه او المجتمع
العربي العربي هو اول من الفلسطيني
واقع الانقسام الفلسطيني الذي لا يستطيع
هذا الانقسام تحريك للشارع الفلسطيني ولا
الشارع العربي ولا حتى
فلذلك المسؤوليه هي مسؤوليه فلسطينيه انا
اعتقد في البدايه انه يجب توحيد الصفوف
الفلسطينيه وقف الانقسام من ثم التوجه
للبلدان العربيه الحكومات العربيه
ومن ثم التوجه للعالم وبدون هذه الخطوات
الثلاثه انا اعتقد انه لن يكون الرابحين
في هذه القويه
في جامعه حيفا كنت معنا من الناصره
[موسيقى]
من جانبها قال زعيم الانفصاليين في الدنيا
قوته بالتعاون مع مجموعتي فاجنر تقترب من
احكام الحصار على المدينه وان القوات
الاوكرانيه تدفع بتعزيزات كبيره نحو
المدينه التي تشتد المعارك عند اطرافها
حسب تعبيره
افادت مصادر محليه للجزيره ان الجيش
التركي استهدف بالمدفعيه الثقيله مواقع ما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في قرى عده
على امتداد الطريق الدولي ام فور شمال
الرقه وفي قرى اخرى برفيتيل تمر شمال
الحسكه وقالت وزاره الدفاع التركيه انه
لاعراق ولا سوريا سيكون ام امنا لمن سمتهم
الارهابيين
نهايه الحصاد شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]